no I don't think America's in decline at
all in fact I I try to emphasize the
fact that while the relative shares of
American Europe in a growing global
economy will decline because it's
unnaturally large the absolute GNP and
the of America and absolute GNP ma
Europe is not going to go down it's
going to grow home and I mean I'm amazed
that Americans and Europeans have
stopped believing that they can compete
in the world of tomorrow how come you
have the world's best universities you
have the world's best companies you have
a very highly educated workforce why are
you afraid of competition why do you
allow Lou Dobbs to set the terms of the
debate in America it's crazy you know
how can the work you know for so long
and America used to preach to the rest
of the world and said open up your
economy is compete it's good for you
guess what they did it they opened up
they want to compete so why are you
running away from the competition
you